hey 42 here the honeybee is one of the
most incredible creatures on planet
Earth each worker bee Graf's tirelessly
its entire life to create just 1/12 of a
teaspoon of honey so when you put your
honey on your toast in the morning you
are eating the entire lifetime
achievements of around 40 bees bees can
communicate with each other with
incredible accuracy via the medium of
Dance bees have a range of different
dances to tell of a hive members where
the best nectar rich flowers are located
through these waggle dances they can
convey information such as distance
direction the angle of the flower is
relative to the Sun and even how good
the flowers are a bee pollination is
crucial to the survival of mankind the
activities of bees nurtures two crops
was humans liver in fact over one-third
of all food you find in the supermarket
requires bee pollination to exist if
there were no bees 33% of all food you
know would be no more and over 90% of
the world's plant requires bees over the
past decade there has been an awful lot
of talk about saving the honeybees and
you may have heard that the honeybee has
been put onto the endangered species
list but this is simply a case of
misinformation being virally spread
around the internet as it often is truth
is the honeybee is absolutely fine
there is nothing to worry about in fact
since 2006 - honey bee population has
increased year-on-year it's true that if
the honeybee population did drastically
reduced
it could cause a total ecosystem
breakdown and the end of the human race
a terrifying fault but with hundreds of
thousands of private beekeepers
worldwide the chances of honeybees
becoming endangered of
basically non-existent sir what was all
the panic about the only bees that were
identified as being endangered were in
fact a tiny handful of obscure bee
species that's how endemic to Hawaii so
unless you happen to live in Hawaii the
bees you see buzzing around you every
day happily pollinating plants and
making honey going absolutely nowhere
but there is an extremely common animal
that poses an even greater threat to the
survival of mankind than the honeybee an
animal that is the universal mascot of
the Internet the internet's court jester
the cat they may have provided you with
countless lols and you should be very
thankful that they have because if the
cat were to become extinct it would
likely be the end of the human race cats
are members of a family of carnivores
called filadyne which includes tigers
cougars and cheetahs and like their
distant cousins cats have sharp
retractable claws amazingly quick
reflexes and sharp teeth that can
effortlessly clump into a preys flesh
but cats have a predatory assets that
they're larger scarier from Lees members
don't a cat has a physics-defying
astonishingly flexible body they are
more agile and big cats such as Tigers
as statistically cats are one of the
best hunters in the entire Animal
Kingdom a study found that Tigers were
only successful at catching their prey
five percent of the time domestic cats
are successful 32% of the time which
means that they are listed as the sixth
most successful hunting animal in the
world but over in Africa there is an
endemic species of cats known as the
black-footed cat which is even more
crazy
this species catches its prey 60% of the
time and they make an average of 14
kills every night making the
black-footed cut the second most
successful predator in the animal
kingdom the only animal more successful
is the African wild dog number one all
this means that cats are the world's
most well adapted and best predator for
catching small rodents rats and mice
being so small cute and defenseless have
been forced to develop extraordinary
reaction times and rapid speeds and
agility so that they can evade predators
yet the domestic cut still manages to
track them and catch them with ease the
statistic boogers don't even hunt
rodents for food it is quite literally a
game to them experts have actually said
that a well-fed cat catches more odors
than a hungry cat because they do it for
entertainment Wow cats are evil and that
is exactly why we need cats for our
survival by hunting and killing rodents
and rabbits cats are doing the world a
vital service yes last time your little
meow Lee Cyrus bought you of gruesome
present she was saving the world
a study in 1997 found that in Britain
alone house cats collectively killed
over 200 million species of wildlife
each year cats therefore play a vital
role in keeping the rodents and rabbit
populations in check all over the world
the phrase breeding like rabbits is no
misnomer
each season a rabbit can give birth to
over a hundred babies and if you think
nuts but rats are even worse a female
rat can mate up to five hundred times
with various males over a six-hour
period and a single pair of
can produce over 2,000 offspring per
year if left to their own devices a pair
of rats can have over half a billion
descendants within just three years but
thankfully rats and other invasive
rodents aren't left to their own devices
they are constantly on a defensive and
their population numbers are maintained
as a healthy balanced level by the hard
work of cats cats are one of the few
animals on the planet and most certainly
the best that can actually hunt and
catch the notoriously slippery rodents
cats therefore are the best method
Mother Nature has for preventing rat
populations from exploding exponentially
and taking over the world without cats
our world would be overrun by rats
within a year or two trillions upon
trillions of rodents and of a small
invasive species would invade every home
every business and every square mile of
the planet but apart from being really
scary why would this be so terrible our
rats really that dangerous yes rats pose
two major threats to mankind and the
entire ecosystem
the first is disease although it is
widely debated by historians it is
widely thought that rats were the main
spreader of the bubonic plague a disease
which almost wiped out Europe whether or
not rats were responsible for the black
death there bacteria spreading abilities
should not be underestimated
rats spend most of their time hanging
out in sewers around piles of rubbish
and of course dead animals these are not
things that one would call
hygienic there can be several thousand
pathogens on just a centimeter
rats fur most of which can be spread to
humans and they don't even have to bite
you disease can be transmitted to humans
through scratches skin contact and worst
of all through their excrement and urine
rats use your een to communicate to mark
territory and just because they need to
go and they will urinate absolutely
anywhere and everywhere come into
contact with it and you're certain to
fall in rats Karen some rather horrific
diseases such as hantavirus pulmonary
syndrome or HPS which can be contracted
by just breathing the air around where a
rat has be HPS restricts your breathing
and is often fatal
once the onset of symptoms has occurred
death can happen in as little as a few
hours so that's scary but that's just a
fraction of the horrors that grass
possess they also carry typhus
Salmonella meningitis and leptospirosis
all of which can be fatal to humans
thankfully most people very rarely come
into contact with rats due to our
relatively hygienic environments and
most importantly the global prevalence
of rat killing cats without cats there
would be no stopping the rapid
multiplication of rats and the
inevitable outbreaks of many horrific
diseases but believe it or not disease
isn't the worst thing that would happen
if rodents took over the world hunger
would be the worst thing
cats have us all fooled thinking they
rely on their owners for survival well
here's the brutal truth your cat doesn't
need you cats are very independent and
even the laziest of house cats can find
food for themselves quite easily if they
choose to they only eat food that you
provide for them because it's easier in
fact when your pet kitty brings you a
dead mouse
use it on your doorstep as a nice little
gift it's actually trying to teach you
how to hunt because it thinks that
you're a pathetic human that can't find
its own food oh dear
but it's this very behavior that has
thus far saved us all
from mass starvation and let me tell you
why you see cats hunt and kill a variety
of rodents such as mice and rats rodents
just love to eat food staples such as
grain the very grain which we all eat
every day farm cats play a vital role in
the modern ecosystem by killing mice and
rats that live in and around storage
barns where grain is kept they stop all
the grain from being consumed or spoiled
by the hungry rodents but if losing all
our grain to rodents wouldn't be bad
enough rats aren't that picky when
they're hungry they will chow down on
just about anything from trash to animal
and human cadavers and any crop or
foodstuff that may be lying around in a
post cataleptic world where rats and
mice are free to multiply by the
billions each and every one of our food
sources would be decimated or disease
ridden before it even leaves the farm a
global famine would be an absolute
certainty but unfortunately disease and
food shortages wouldn't be the end of
our troubles the entire ecosystem would
also collapse due to the domino effect
Macquarie Island is a super remote
island owned by Australia viewing the
feral cat population on the island as
somewhat of a nuisance because they were
killing the local seabirds a cat
eradication program was started and
between 1985 and 2000 every single feral
cat on McQuarrie Island was killed and
then of course within no time at all the
local rat and
rabbit populations quadrupled and they
in turn caused massive devastation to
the island vegetation depleting all food
sources for the countless over animal
species that they shared the island with
and the scientists on the island soon
found out that rats just love to feed on
the eggs of the very sea birds which
they intended to save the local seabird
population declined at an astonishing
rate due to the plentiful amount of rats
and the lack of cats the ecosystem is a
very delicate balancing act and this
experiment just goes to show that we
shouldn't mess with it because the
tiniest of changes can have enormous
irreparable effects humans have still
not formulated an effective method of
pest control for routes the array of rat
poisons available just flat-out don't
work at least not in the long run rats
are smarter than we give them credit for
and as soon as one of them is chief yes
that is what a group of rats is called
dies from eating rat poison the rest of
the mischeif learns not to trust that
food location or that food in the future
even that's or they employ a super taste
of rats called Remy to check all our
food before consumption in recent years
scientists have even found groups of
rats that have developed a natural
immunity to rat poisons until our
artificial rodent deterrents are
developed further and become more
effective cats remain our only truly
effective weapon against them so as long
as we have muggy we should be okay that
is of course until rats learn how to
weaponize cucumbers thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
click here to support me on patreon
which really helps out the channel and
you can get some cool rewards click here
to watch another video and if you
haven't already don't forget to
subscribe